all right well Gage uh so playing
Dracula has been a lifelong dream of
yours why was it this lifelong dream for
you to portray Dracula as soon as I read
the book Dracula I
um I thought there was something in the
character that was profoundly compelling
I think Dracula is although it's a
supernatural character he's really
saying something about the human
experience which is if you supplant an
addiction to blood with an addiction to
alcohol or heroin or sex you can see
that that's those are human issues that
people contend with and then you factor
in eternal life or Eternal Undead
experience you're going to get your
heart broken time and time again and be
betrayed and I think that's something
people can also relate to so it's a very
although Supernatural is a very human
kind of character something far more
deeper than the spooky element of it I
am
Direction
okay obviously we're dealing with a
little bit more than just narcissism
here yeah well I think as actors we're
always looking for the connection that
makes it feel authentic that we can tap
into so we're not feeling like we're
acting we're feeling like we're being
what were some of the appearances the
mannerisms the characteristics that your
Dracula had to have I think that in
terms of the look I was extremely uh
interested in Christopher Lee's
appearance as Dracula my personal
favorite Dracula and the hammer horror
films I love the way he had that 60s
hairdo and the way he dressed
[Music]
in terms of influences in my own life
and I don't mean this in a negative way
my father August Coppola he was always
the smartest man of any room he walked
in and he knew and he made sure we knew
it and I thought the way he spoke he had
this minute Atlantic accent and he spoke
with distinction you see Nicholas and I
thought okay that's perfect because he's
a literature professor and this Dracula
should sound like him oh my gosh this
had to be just a satisfying character it
was very satisfying I mean you nailed it
man thank you from the look to the Walk
The Talk
I need your assistance I'm coming Martha
what was it like being on the receiving
end of Cage's Dracula Hulk oh it was
truly magical I mean that was that was
the it made me giddy it many times
because I was like I'm getting to be on
set have a front row seat to see
Nicholas Cage played Dracula which is
like that's a once in a lifetime and and
I'm so excited for people to get to see
it because it's truly iconic in every
way well YouTube Knicks go Toe to Toe I
mean you're bringing it as well but you
know Dracula here is a horrible terrible
just downright awful boss yeah it's
perfectly honest yeah the emotional core
of this story is what we were both drawn
to this toxic codependent relationship
that you know they obviously in the past
did have good times together but when we
meet them in this store it's 100 years
on from the classic Dracula story and
they have grown to this place where
Dracula knows how to manipulate and love
bomb and trick Renfield and but Renfield
is also someone who has made all these
mistakes on his own and has to come to
terms with that and is living with a lot
of regret the psychological game he's
playing with you it's unreal and then
you you know you're reciting these
affirmations to yourself to get through
yeah
regain that I know but it also brought a
sense of Comedy as well you know in in
those heavier kind of gory moments
um but going back to Horrible Bosses
what is a horrible terrible boss story
that you might have oh you've got you've
got you've got do you have some well it
I I won't mention any names but yeah I
was on a certain production and I
remember I
I was in a very dramatic moment and I
was pounding on a glass in a certain
hospital and the glass broke and I cut
my hand I was with my co-star and the
director said now you two are gonna have
to have a bit more discipline if you
expect me to get through this movie
without losing my Peppa I thought well
that's a good model for Dracula and I
try to use that line I did use that line
in the scene with the Picasa student
you're gonna have a bit more dismal I
kept trying to bring it back but I'm not
mentioning any names the thing about
narcissistic bosses and people and and
uh
sociopathic relationships the sociopath
is always a master of the bait and
switch like throughout the kindness and
then switch and knock them dead you know
and I think Dracula is a maestro oh
without a doubt like the master
manipulator of doing just that without a
doubt now do you have a terrible boss
story there oh I've been pretty
fortunate that most of my bosses have
been very kind I mean and given good
environments to work in but there's
definitely been a few that have had jobs
and and being on set I think everyone
always performs better when they're
feeling valued and like they're having
fun and it's a safe environment so
luckily that we're seeing less and less
of it nowadays I think yeah good and
this director Chris McKay really
fostered that that feeling of creativity
and feeling free to bring ideas and
collaboration well it is seen on the
screen that is for sure I will no longer
tolerate abuse I deserve happiness
okay you deserve only suffering Nicholas
Holt's character has to eat bugs to gain
power so what are you really eating on
set Nick is it the real deal something
fake it it depends on the day like the
Cockroaches were actually just made of
caramel so they were actually quite
delicious
um the worms were gummy worms and they
were in crushed up Oreo biscuit really
like the fake Earth so those again were
delicious
um but on the real bug days it was
mainly crickets which again uh they were
kind of dried and then flavored there
was salt and vinegar and Smoky bacon
flavor so again pretty delicious you'd
have little bit to get stuck in your
teeth but it was fine did you ever try
some okay
my bug eating days are longer yeah and
you were more you were I guess partial
to blood right right
very sweet like a Caro syrup a kind of
like a thick sugar-based molasses
although red yeah sticky very sticky oh
the movie Magic right yeah age you've
had some iconic rolls you can add this
one to the list what is a line or a
lines that are recited to you most from
your fans
oh well I guess from the longest time uh
from back from Moonstruck I would walk
through the airport and people just had
a habit of saying
snap out of it snap out of it I did get
slapped a few times no you did not yeah
yeah I did and that's okay you know it's
part of the job humble's the old ego
right correct we'll play does someone
think it's okay to slap you and do that
you know I mean the commitment
yeah I think maybe I'll cast them in
something who knows do you have a
particular favorite line that you've
delivered
from a past character
um this here Jack is a symbol of my
individuality and my belief in personal
freedom that was from Wild at Heart
Duality my belief in personal freedom
Nick you're currently in production on
another Blood sucking feature film
correct yes
Nosferatu have you been hit by the old
vampire bug I suppose I have I mean this
was obviously a reinterpretation of
these characters in a completely new
original idea that was so exciting
um Nosferatu is is a remake of the
classic film but also it's very exciting
because Robert Eggers is directing he's
one of my favorite directors at the
moment I think he's he's just incredible
with what he creates so
um it's going it's going well and
hopefully people like this
interpretation of it will you guys work
your your magic in this film in
particular very fun ride very fun
interpretation it is a ride yeah
foreign